depuis quelques années un phénomène venu
tout droit des etats-unis s'est installé
dans les rues de nos grandes villes
le street maji monnaie approchait a
brossé vous approchez vous avez envie de
voir la magie opère mettez-vous par
michel seydoux sioniste d'un nouveau
genre il en est un qui défraie la
chronique
tim fisker l'illusion de lévitation en
pleine rue de tim fils coeur est devenu
en quelques mois un véritable phénomène
oui
possible
premier entraîneur
il
on était hallucinant impressionnant un
truc de fou y a rien en dessous il n'y a
rien entre cépie j'étais au moins là il
se soumet au walhalla l'engagement et au
et non caveiracois c'est est saisissant
la performance de fisker si parfaite que
la presse internationale commence à se
poser de questions tim fisker illusion
ou réels pouvoirs au fco bien sûr des
ruines il ya un truc
même si j'ai le plus grand respect pour
le travail de tim et ce soit c'est du
travail
ces rumeurs à propos de ces soi-disant
vrai pouvoir or le deviennent vraiment
dangereux c'est complètement faux donc
je confirme qu'ils entrent qui poursuit
sur lequel non non il y en a pas le
moindre indice bien non non mais bien
tout est que vous devriez observer la
foule est meilleur dans l'art de
l'illusion semble pas le véritable
artiste et qu'elle reste
l'assistant
même si quelquefois se pourrait-il que
tim fisker bénéficient de l'aide d'un
complice dissimulés parmi les passants
difficile à dire une chose est sûre si
tim fisker travail avec un partenaire
l'illusion est savamment orchestré c'est
un coup de maître
nous avons une discrètement suivi team
fisc heures après sa performance
nous l'avons retrouvé en compagnie d'un
inconnu nous filmons la scène en caméra
cachée je ne passe pas le chapeau
n'attendait toi tu es tout le temps dans
la lumière le public applaudit tu es
tout le temps à la télé c'est pas facile
pour moi quand même et un complice et un
complice à passe pas à la télé ouais
mais un complice un complice cpi ce
train de se faire du fric là le truc mon
bousman attend un peu de temps en
attendant pourquoi est ce que tu veux
pas passer le chapeau merde quand il
passait le chapon tu vas jouer de
l'accordéon au trocadéro tu me fais pas
chier à l'eau et physique qui me payer
les consoles à nous avons réussi à
retrouver une personne qui aurait des
teams fils coeur il ya quelques années à
concevoir son numéro de lévitation et
qui a accepté de s'exprimer devant nos
caméras
oui j'ai ma sensibilité oui j'aimais
desiderata toute ma carrière je n'ai été
qu'un binôme toujours à 2 toujours à 2
vous croyez que c'est facile tous les
jours
ah non il ya des tensions il ya des
réflexions quand quand j'ai rencontré
tim jeu je sortais d'une collaboration
difficile avec une personne exigeante
qui n'avait pas toujours la patience
avec autrui
alors quand j'ai vu que ça prenait le
même chemin avec steam j'ai préféré me
préserver j'ai préféré dire stop
et bien vous savez il vient et ça peut
être très difficile de trouver un bon
assistant d'ici vous prônez linda ici en
français moi comment mais qu'est ce que
tu nous fais chier là tu peux pas parler
français mais je peux essayer si tu
regardes et tu as ton cv à jour pas
parce que au pôle emploi ils sont assez
ric-rac avec ça
hall on l'a pas du tout à ça et aller
maintenant
ouais j'ai fini ma journée mois et
costumes on discute mais pas comme ça je
peux plus rien faire là j'ai plus à
patates
je me repose déontologiquement c'est
grave ce que tu fais là on ne doit pas
de discuter en public la ferme ta gueule
alors je tire la demande et moi en fait
qu'est ce que tu veux 75 euros nets par
jour à chier ok bah casse toi
vas-y casse-toi bartois d'accord comme
on en connaît pas la part dont on voit
là oui oui mais j'ai dit qu'il fallait
pas qu'on me reconnaisse années j'étais
pas du tout quand je suis désolé malgré
notre encaisse la question reste entière
tim fisker roi de l'illusion ou
véritable homme volant
ce cas
au portel